going to school every morning
spending your day together with other
kids in classrooms
none of this can be taken for granted
anymore education
in times of the pandemic our topic today
welcome to dw or dw's kobe 19 special
on this good friday a public holiday in
many parts of the world
but soon the struggle starts again
trying to keep up with the curriculum
despite lockdown
every morning the via royale family has
to decide
which of their four children gets to do
online schooling that day
the family in the bolivian capital la
paz only has
one smartphone just like many other
families in the country
then there are also problems with the
internet connection
there are so many different apps
classroom zoom and so on
and most of them only work with a
high-end phone and decent
internet when i go to work at 10 am
there's only one suitable phone left
here
and so three children are left with
nothing
[Music]
the platform for virtual school lessons
was set up by the bolivian education
ministry
the government insists the system has
been set up in a way that ensures
everyone can access
the online classes
we set up a timetable that regulates who
can use the platform when
each day is allocated for a different
school grade so it's not like all the
children have to use it every day
but obviously the system still needs
further optimization
[Music]
using the school platform is free of
charge but accessing the internet is
very expensive in bolivia
a problem that christian leon has long
been urging the government to address
he set up an advocacy group to draw
attention to the problem
bolivia only got fiber optic internet in
2018.
the network
bolivia's national telecommunications
company states that one gigabyte of data
costs five dollars
a price not every family can afford says
viviana kumara
only those with more money can afford
internet access
so education is no longer free in
bolivia because
right now the more money you have the
more you can learn
the education ministry has promised to
provide 30
000 computers to at least improve the
hardware problem
but that won't be enough for all many
families like the villa roes
will have to continue finding their own
solutions to ensure their children can
take part in online schooling
until the vaccine rollout advances
enough for children to return to the
classroom
should schools remain open or should
they be closed to stop the spread of the
virus
let's bring in jonathan suk a principal
expert in emergency preparedness at the
european center
for disease prevention and control in
stockholm
good to have you with us and i know that
you conducted a study into covit 19 in
schools
when it comes to keeping schools open or
not what are your findings
thank you very much for having us first
of all we're we're constantly updating
um the literature and we're reviewing uh
the studies on this
we're finding that of course any like
any uh what we call
non-pharmaceutical interventions if you
close something in society that leads to
less
social mixing so it will have an impact
on the overall uh
transmission as well as cov2 so it's
potentially important to measure what
we're seeing
and what the most recent literature
shows is that
on the second wave and more recent
closures of schools have less of an
impact than they did in the first wave
and this has to do with
schools have adopted in the way that
they've been practicing they're not
operating as they did in pre-pandemic
levels but they're doing more measures
internally to to keep them
safe to keep students safe to try to
keep teachers safe
and those measures have an impact and so
we think that
it's it may be necessary to close
schools there's no question about that
with the new variant circulating
but the general contestants that uh
debacho unisa vsdc have
relates to trying to keep schools open
um and closing them only as a last
resort first of all
could you define that last i mean who or
what determines what
this last resort would be
that has to be decision makers in the
local context to understand the
transmission levels
understand the burden on the healthcare
system of the current levels of icu and
so on
and who really can do a proper
assessment of what measures are in place
in schools
if everything has been tried within the
schools to really keep your transmission
down
or not and then what sorts of levels of
schools let's also not
make it a binary thing schools do not
need to be just fully open or fully
closed they're hybrid models
they're different age groups that are
important to consider so it's not just a
whole
either or situation in most cases either
there's a lot of options there for
authority makers doesn't
necessarily make it more easy to to uh
come to the right conclusion
uh do we actually know where children
catch the virus in the first place
is that happening at school do they get
from teachers from other children or do
they
bring the virus into the school because
they catch it at home
that's a fantastic question and we've
been trying to
understand that better in terms of the
school settings themselves
what we've actually found is that there
are very few documented instances where
you see large
outbreaks in school settings so
transmission certainly happens
in schools but but the literature from
many different countries in europe and
globally suggests that
there's not necessarily the need for
lots of outbreaks in school settings
what we wonder and what we need to learn
more about of course are what happens
to children not just in the school
itself but after school extracurricular
activities
on the way to school on the way home
from school and of course as you
mentioned in household
settings there's also the possibility
for transmission so you don't have
precise numbers on that but the the
information on on schools is that they
can actually be operated safely without
too many
instances of of large outbreaks i mean
this
these still quite trying and very
confusing times a lot of parents
feel safer having their kids around and
uh
some in some countries where schools
reopen decided to not
send their kids back to school because
they don't trust the situation do they
have a point
it's really hard to to assess that on
without knowing the specific
details of the context in which uh they
have made those
decisions i certainly understand why
people are worried
there's a lot of research also from from
germany a large study just from scotland
recently that shows at least for the the
parents of younger children
there does not appear to be an increased
risk to to the parents
catching the virus from from their
children even at periods when they've
been sent back to to school
we also know that by and large the the
number of
severe outcomes in children is very very
low um
we're not seeing any change in that even
with the new
variants we've been following very
closely dated millions of cases and
and children particularly younger
children follow this age
the age gradient so we know that elderly
continue to be
the most risk followed by by older
adults but children
really have very very rare instances of
severe outcomes such as hospitalization
or death
right but we do know that children can
carry
and they can spread the virus so what do
you make of the concept of homeschooling
wouldn't that in this
moment in time make most sense
yeah it's it's true that children can
can transmit the virus
as i mentioned it appears to to be the
case that they transmitted somewhat less
than adults do and they appear also to
be less susceptible to the virus than
adults do i'm by no means an expert in
education and homeschooling but i what
we've understood
from the vast amount of literature that
exists that it is very difficult for
children to to be home
and we understand as well that there is
a gradient so the so
learning loss from children is less for
in children from
from well-off backgrounds but from
deprived backgrounds
vulnerable backgrounds this can be
really detrimental to the the education
and even the health and well-being of
children so all these things have to be
taken into account
there's no easy answer i really
appreciate that but but these are the
things that
decision makers do need to consider
indeed a lot of food
for thought there for decision makers
jonathan zuck from the european
center for disease prevention and
control in stockholm
thank you so much for your time happy
easter thank you very much
thank you well in time for your
questions now over to derek
how long can vaccine side effects last
does discomfort indicate it's working
i want to leave all the the speculation
about blood clotting
and the astrazeneca vaccine behind for a
minute
and focus on what we know for certain
about
common minor side effects reported
in connection with covet vaccines pretty
much
all of the ones approved so far in in
various parts of the world
appear to be pretty reactogenic which
means
they regularly cause mild side effects
like
like pain and swelling at the injection
site as well as things like like fatigue
headache fever chills
or aching joints the single shot
johnson johnson vaccine appears to cause
those effects
somewhat less often in two-dose
mrna vaccines they seem to occur
more commonly after the second dose
while the opposite seems to hold true
for the astrazeneca vaccine
another point worth mentioning is that
that younger people
seem to react more often and more
powerfully
than the elderly it's thought that's
because they have
more responsive immune systems
authorities
say the symptoms can last a few days
but but in most of the first-hand
reports that i read
they subsided within 36 hours
the good news is that side effects while
unpleasant
are actually a sign that the vaccine is
doing
what it's supposed to do which is laying
the groundwork
for an immune response so that if you
are infected with the virus
your body can get to work straight away
wiping it out
um personally i'm more than happy to
experience
a day or two of discomfort if i know
that i'll be protected afterwards
from a potentially life-threatening case
of covet 19.
that sounds like a really great deal to
me
and finally as shopping malls are closed
amid pandemic lockdowns
a school in the u.s state of vermont
decided to make use of the empty space
students can now take lessons in this
form of macy's more why not
well that's all for now thanks for
watching